let's take a look at this major uptake
from the FDA today we limited the
authorized use of the Jansen covid-19
vaccine to those 18 and over for whom
other authorized approved vaccines are
not accessible or clinically appropriate
and to those who elect Jansen because
they would otherwise not receive a
coveted vaccine so that last part's
particularly interesting
but the news
is that it's over the blood clot clot
risk U.S restricts use of Johnson and
Johnson coveted vaccine over rare blood
clot risk the FDA said the shot should
be given only to those who request it or
cannot receive other vaccines and you
have to be 18 and older
my understanding is that the data on
this is not I don't I don't think it's
new that we've known about the risk of
blood clots for some time it was
actually taken off the market for some
time
so I'm wondering if I suppose my issue
initially that we can we can jump into
here
how many people should have gotten this
FDA warning some time ago if we knew
about the blood clot risk yeah I mean
well if this is something we knew about
everyone should have been able to know
they should have been able to make an
informed decision about what they were
putting in their body and the risk it
posed to them because this information
was kept from us because we couldn't
really accelerate the dialogue around
the vaccines in order to get the best
information about it because anyone who
contradicted The Narrative was told that
they were not trusting the science
there are serious consequences yeah this
we're talking about human lives here
right it's a in a society an ideal
Society immediately everyone should know
if there's a problem like this but in
hyper sensitive sensorious areas you
can't that's the big problem with with
censorship like not censorship in
general but just like Mis
misappropriated censorship or over over
censor what are you gonna so I was gonna
say they that the establishment likes to
do this um retroactive fact-checking
thing where let's say uh today a man uh
gets in a rocket ship and flies off and
he screams I'm going to the moon and
we're like oh wow that was crazy and
then we come on the show and we say did
you hear the story about that guy who
got the rocket ship and yelled he was
going to the Moon that crazy
a week later the news comes out he
actually went to Mars and what they'll
do is they'll say fact check false will
get flagged and the right story saying
they spread disinformation about the man
of the rocket ship who's actually going
to Mars so what happens is we can come
out and talk about lab leak for instance
in covid and we'll say based on the
current contextual information our best
assessment is this
a week later the news changes the fact
Checkers then take your old story and
call you fake news based on information
that came out a week later you see the
games let me let me let me show you
that's not what happens to fauci though
ever oh right right no but they hit a
lot of this information too we knew we
knew about the blood clots we knew about
especially with women they were having
issues with their menstrual cycles and
they covered it up and all the headlines
were it doesn't affect your period it
doesn't affect your menstrual cycle the
blood clots are for the first few months
that was the story and then a few months
later they're like oh by the way women
are reporting issues with their
menstrual cycles take a look at this
from breaking 9-1-1 they say strange how
the ap's Tweet same exact headline isn't
flagged as misleading the AP said U.S
Regulators strictly limited who can
receive J J's covid-19 vaccine due to a
rare but serious risk of blood clots the
FDA said the shot should only be given
to adults okay so we we know that take a
look at this photo
breaking 9-1-1 posting an image breaking
FDA restricts J J covid-19 vaccine due
to blood clot risk misleading learn why
Health officials consider covid-19
vaccines safe for most people here's the
best part that misleading tag linked to
an April 1st fact check
so old information fact checking a new
breaking story Anna could have been an
April Fool's joke for all we know that's
right how are we supposed to know for
sure well right now if you look at
breaking 9-1-1 they've they've they've
actually removed the misleading uh flag
on it but they do give breaking 9-1-1
according to newsguard a not they give
it a fake news here's here's what gets
even better the headline used by
breaking 9-1-1 is identical to the New
York Post now I know they said the same
as the AP the aps headline was different
it says serious but rare theirs doesn't
but the New York Post is identical
that's the problem with censorship so
now we have
we have the story coming out from Pfizer
this big data dump and it's actually
quite alarming and the problem is the
people working at YouTube right now the
sensors many of them are probably not
even in the US
they have no idea so even nisk even this
story right now breaking the FDA has
strictly restricted the J the JJ vaccine
we run the risk of getting banned
because YouTube sensors are looking at a
little they got like a laminated placard
it says when to ban someone they're like
if they talk bad about vaccines you got
to ban them uh well they are yeah
probably more specific they have a slack
Channel where they send it out this
article and they're like is this
bannable they're like well no that's got
this but if you know and then they they
cross-reference it with like if they do
it in this context yeah if it's in this
context no no no no no no and then they
have to make individuals these are
outsourced um these are outsourced the
people who are doing the Banning many of
them aren't in this country and on slack
channels and I think the fact that we're
looking at Twitter this is why I'm
making the point Twitter censored uh
breaking911 due to month old information
it's a new story that goes to show you
the people who are flagging it are not
communicating on what this news is but
they're not doing it for peanuts either
it's always in the best interest of
these bigwigs like the hunter Biden
story that was the most egregious of all
but the hunter Biden story they're
protecting big Pharma it's all of these
things it's not peanuts that they're
going after but that's why we need the
open source algorithm that's why it's so
important and what elon's doing is
incredible I will I will say to Ian's
Point freeing the code the one thing
that we absolutely need to do is free
the algorithm the recommendation all of
that stuff needs to be open source I
don't think these companies should be
allowed to hide that because what do
they do behind the scenes they lie to
Congress about censorship manipulation
there was a really great question from a
Republican
I can't remember who they asked they
said why is it that when you sign up for
Twitter you are shown nothing but
Democrats to follow really yep if you
were in Washington DC and you and you
sign up for Twitter on a brand new
computer it gives you all Democrats and
they were like that must be an oversight
on our part free the code so last
Tuesday yeah exactly release the code
and let us know if you're lying or not
because it's one thing you know we have
this discussion the other night about
whether all of the code should be
released well the infrastructure that
holds the building up I disagree with
Ian on but in terms of how they're
manipulating what we see and what we
think you shouldn't be allowed to do a
lot of people message me about security
through obfuscation which is part of
keeping your security code private and
they said that's been completely
obliterated and is useless you need to
open source the security code too so it
can be poked and prodded and then
resolved and made stronger but when you
say free the code you got to be specific
you need to make these things become
interoperable and I agree that you need
algorithm I'm just I'm saying
specifically for now where I would agree
on releasing the code to the public is
Elon Musk says he when he gets to
Twitter he wants to make the algorithm
open source and he should that way
everybody knows that they're not
manipulating politics I think they're
already doing cleanup though I don't
think they want us to know and we saw
that the unthrottling of so many
accounts I was like wow all of a sudden
I have all these things I gained like
200 000 followers in a few days it's
crazy I had been you know stagn you know
I was still gaining but it was stagnant
for the most part and then all of a
sudden it was like the floodgates open
up for so many people but I think
they're they're doing cleanup and how
fast they removed that warning shows it
too that they're they're a little more
cognizant well I tweeted to Elon I said
hey yo Elon Musk check this an old fact
check has restricted a new story about
the vaccine it got a thousand retweets I
think I'm not saying it was me I'm
saying a bunch of people were tweeting
out like crazy yeah for sure what's
going on yeah you contributed for sure
you contributed to that the one problem
with open sourcing the algorithm here
and seeing is that it doesn't stop an
errant administrator from censoring
something in India if they're working
remote and they they like are like no
we're gonna we're gonna downvote that
you'll you may be able to track that it
happened but you still don't know who
did it and why they did it that's all
like business talk and now you're saying
do we have to open up their slack
channels so we can watch them
communicate and that's like basically
the beginning of the end of the
corporation if you're gonna but is that
also Justified let's let's talk about
that man when it I'd be willing to bet a
large sum of money that if you took
Twitter's internal slack channels which
is their internal communication between
employees assuming it's slack or some
other yeah whatever whatever they're
using yeah I don't want to drag slack
Slack's a great company but um if
they're using some kind of messaging
service and you got to see the full
archive there's going to be tons of
people saying can we ban the
conservatives how do we get these people
off the channels and we know this it's
not opinion because project Veritas has
already released videos where you have
employees these big tech companies
saying we try to get them banned we try
to get them removed that was Media
Matters there was Media Matters who was
bragging about getting project Veritas
and James O'Keefe ripped off that
reference I was giving was actually I
think an employee from one of these
companies really saying that inside the
company we are trying to get them banned
but yes but then they also got Media
Matters bragging about getting and I
tweeted it out for them I had never been
mentioned by Media Matters that I know
of and I tweeted it out and I was making
fun of that whoever was in the video all
of a sudden I was mentioned in a Media
Matters article for nothing for my for
my children's book after I made fun of
them
yeah Media Matters is an interesting
organization we've had a couple
conversations about them and it's funny
because you two are going back and forth
about these different examples of the
left basically being caught trying to
suppress right-wing content even though
they claim that's something that isn't
really happening isn't it interesting
how the stories that conservatives
promote about how our side is being
maligned or unfairly treated are
actually true in literally every single
instance of the left upholding its
persecution narrative with the story of
some kind of hate crime is completely
nonsensical and turns out to be untrue
when you look into it just a little bit
I just want to shout out that Gizmodo
article it's the best example of this
Facebook former Facebook workers
routinely suppressed conservative news
outlets this is what kicked off the
whole story about censorship and I see
that and it's 2016. I think I'm working
for Fusion at the time and I was like
hey look at this news that I know and
trust wow they were censoring
conservatives
I say that it's happening and I get
called a liar or right-wing for saying
it Facebook's weird though because then
they were giving a lot of money to
targeted Victory right and that was a
republican group to make things against
Tick Tock as a competitor so they're
weird they'll do things like that but
then they'll but they'll now they give
money to conservatives and so they're
still censoring them but it's just such
a weird relationship because Facebook I
feel like is different because they just
do whatever for the money whereas I feel
like Twitter is a little more beholden
to the Mob
um but you're seeing me how fast they
clean this up it took them how long for
the hunter Biden story and this this
this disclaimer's gone within what a day
I think it's really fascinating didn't
fauci say we're out of the pandemic or
something like that
still existed well maybe you should pay
attention to the fact she thought he
banned it I thought he vanished would
you go to www.pouture.com
Bill Gates was like when we get into the
next pandemic he's getting everybody
fearful about the next one he's like
we're releasing an update
there's the the chicken flu now that
they're freaking out about but what so
do you brought up isn't that already a
thing bird flu no but it's like jumped
the new one jump to a person I didn't I
kind of feel like I derailed your
comment about fauci was there something
you were gonna yeah that he said
something about we're out of the
pandemic already I I saw something like
that and I'm just wondering you know
myth and formed posted that clip of The
Joe Rogan podcast where I asked Vegeta
would they ban someone for vaccine
misinformation and she says no it's not
against our policies and uh you know
sure if they went did it so their
policies changed because the pandemic
happened now the pandemic's over is
there the same level of risk yeah this
from washingtonpost.com if fauci says
U.S is out of coronavirus quote pandemic
phase well there you go fauci that's
from the science and I say that as a
joke he is not the science so does
Twitter now give up its emergency powers
and stops Banning people for these
things because it's no longer a greater
risk no I mean when does when does any
organization government or otherwise
take power from the public because of
some kind of emergency and then give it
back once the emergency is over I mean
uh-oh what's this WebMD says fauci
clarifies out of the pandemic phase uh
oh he said Wayne I need another time
cover what what what what are they
saying here he said we don't have 900
000 new infections a day we are at a low
level now so if you're asking are we out
of the pandemic phase we are
okay so all right pandemic phase is over
all right so do we all move on is that
it or yeah well it's over till they
don't want it to be over anymore this is
part of what's so frustrating about this
entire thing they can flip the narrative
in a second and then they say oh the
science changes and that would be all
well and good if they were allowing any
dissident who tried to provide the
public data that didn't support their
Narrative of voice right but they
silence everybody and if the science is
always changing then that's all the more
reason to allow people to speak out when
they have a perspective that conflicts
with the current narrative because the
current narrative could always turn out
to be untrue but they want to have it
both ways the science is settled it's
unchanging shut up and listen to us we
were wrong oh well you know science is a
process it evolves over time thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there